yeah Monday here we are buddy boy look
at you have we started we have started
my friend you're on your phone you know
I mean sorry man what's going on how was
your weekend
pretty good what'd you do I have amnesia
I'm trying to think well what did you do
to by what I was I was at home arts
what's the movies you watch the movies
them at home the movie what you watch
Wow
Trent training day training day what all
the movies you said you won't you watch
the movies what other movies did you
watch not what I went to the movies good
Jesus Christ but oh it you went to
training day that's in the theaters I
didn't know training day was still in
the theaters hey man
no I didn't what what's going on but
where were you most of Saturday you're
at home I was at home okay here's the
problem I spoke to the people that live
in your home and they didn't see you all
day Saturday this Saturday this Saturday
yeah this Saturday what why you were
there yeah we're at the house were you
in were you wearing your invisible cloak
no I don't have one okay so maybe you
weren't there do you can you jog your
memory and maybe think where you were
this Saturday this Saturday let's see I
went to the gym and then you saw is that
a picture of you are you dancing there
are you in shorts and nothing else who
sent that to you who sent that to me you
don't think I have eyes on you let me
ask you a question Gary saying that
don't worry about who's Tanner you talk
to Gary don't worry about Gary right you
have my [ __ ] your [ __ ] what do you mean
your [ __ ] what are we talking about yeah
my cradle hey did you talk to Jerry and
I've been doing your kratom what have
you been doing kratom why are you
scratching your neck you've been doing
cradle have you been doing kratom or not
by the truck you got kratom on you
answer the question later now yeah right
now is my question my
okay yeah do you have any in your pocket
try stuffing capsules in my left pocket
no hey hey no no he what's going on hey
bro
let's go oh god damn it
one two three four five six seven eight
nine nine not seven but nine there's
only one thing we can do and that's the
beat the [ __ ] addiction oh you know
with a golden shoe hey release the demon
around turn around
you gotta get it on your rumpy-pumpy you
been a bad egg and only pain brings you
to the other side look at me look at me
I'm gonna give you a hickey
in a straight way you gotta get no more
drugs right no then [ __ ] sorry you guys
had to roll you said why did he suck we
were trying to suck bro I was trying
sometimes you have to suck the kratom
out of someone's neck that's a fact no
you try to suck the nectar up my dick
hey man I never said that
trying to suck that kratom neck I never
said that I was giving you a hickey that
sweet sweet cradle nectar I was told
they're not addictive Brennan was doing
some kratom this weekend and that's a
fact I was told they're not addictive
and they are I went to jail I'll pop one
I thought that's a funny feeling yeah up
and down this road before
uh-huh I've heard this tune I'll pop
down on it like a warm heart over like a
warm hug yeah oh boy
yeah apparently you got some in your
glove compartment box mm-hmm I've taken
them everyday sense really I'm addicted
right well I heard that you had your
brother on a little recon on kratom and
there's arguments for both I mean
there's lots of things out there that is
addictive and there's some say it's not
and then you know I don't know man
yeah chin takes it all the goddamn time
we get him you do huh
no wonder you go nowhere in the week you
take it all the time chin I do take it
daily I'm worried now there you go bro
daily uh maybe over a year how did you
come across knowing about it I wanted
something like not like prescription
drugs I want something natural to help
with pain that's why I originally took
it what pain do you have back pain from
carrying the show from watching I don't
know just growing up well that sounds
like an excuse to take drugs
I said back pain uh well but I think
that kratom is probably has narcotic
effects like just as it's natural you
know what I mean you can die from
aspirins pretty natural basically willow
bark but you can get a bleeding stomach
rhythms uh arsenic is natural and you
live - opiate for sure there at the same
family barbecue well that's are sharing
a rack of ribs I said it's like it it
reacts to the same opioid sensors or
opiate sensors but it's not really an
opiate I don't know what cause I mean I
had some pharmacists like do legite
pharmacists and then some doctors reach
out I'll say there's two stories here
you know there's Mike Bell's kratom
story there's the doctors kratom story
and then there's the truth so somewhere
there's you know we would we would want
to lean more toward the scientific
evidence what does that say drug it
needs to be studied it's not studied
that's the thing well it studied in
Thailand right they've made it illegal
yeah heroin stuff so what what is uh
what did the doctors and farms to say
about say it's addictive okay I'm gonna
go with the pharmacist in the dye
Staters I heard it's mildly addictive
like the wake coffee is that's what I
was read I don't know doctor says that's
what they say so you seem like oh it's
not a big deal why would he want you to
take it anything that addictive is gonna
be you know I feel like choose defending
his house guy that's right that's wrong
you give every day every day
anything you need to take every day is
not good how many I look at it like the
way you take coffee how many pills
always compared to coffee how many yeah
I don't
into pills they sell them in power to
form do you find you have to take more
powder every day no okay so I've been
taking the same not for for quite well
that's significant every no ain't
killers apparently according to Chris
and according to up your you keep you
have to keep taking more right yeah yeah
whereas it if you've been taking kratom
for a year and you haven't had to up
your dose yeah that's that actually is
at least there is a difference there
right toast to Newark oxy cotton
whatever yeah you need to keep taking
more from what I observe in the same
effect so everybody will death yeah I
mean now did I take for kratom and
organize my sock drawer yeah I did yeah
I did
drive around dots colors I know but you
can't be doing blow in the middle of it
you can't be doing meth and blow between
the pills you might be right mm-hmm I
wish I looked up more before he came in
so I could kind of well math is
fascinating cuz I had a girlfriend used
to meth and that's great for you and she
in heard this she and the guy she's
cheat on me with uh and he was a dealer
and they would do it and he she would
clean she would clean you stay up all
night and really clean I mean get a
toothbrush in the nooks and crannies of
things so that there's a corner with a
little dirt you get that nice and spots
when you're going to I met that except
room sometimes it can be so outrageously
clean and organized it's crazy and he
would literally like kind of he would
label literally everything in his pantry
with with with perfect lettering like he
would paint perfect lettering and
everything I deduct of methods yeah
productive and all that energy to your
Rob Poland dick socket well there was
then they're gonna clean that up that's
what happens though they will suck the
nectar out of your dick no no there's
your sweet yeah yeah there's some
[ __ ] and then and then go to your
bunny hole and clean that up too there's
some [ __ ] that goes on oh yeah I
don't know if I told you how I don't
know if I told you how I caught my girl
cheating on me I don't know if I told
you this did I ever tell you this
alright I was walking I was walking with
dogs at night
Venice mm-hmm then I was like I think
she was with that guy and I think she
was doing meth and I think she was
[ __ ] all office and I was like mmm
let me see it's because she had a little
drawing on her back and I went that's an
intricate drawing and she didn't do that
like a tattoo or Sun I don't think that
was her friend it was just a beautiful
it was a beautiful message a smart a lot
of time back oh yeah it was a detailed
magic marker to to always draw her back
well they're balls deep and well there
you go now this is a girl a love read
weird way to that lock don't in it well
when you're on Matthew you you [ __ ] and
do detailed drawings okay that are
worthy of a museum
Wow and I was like that's some good work
that's some good detailed work and so
I'm I'm walking and I'm like and you
know things start to they start to fall
together add up she just like you're
like you're watching first 48 you've
never seen you've never seen The
Sopranos but the one of the great scenes
is when Tony Soprano has food poisoning
and he keeps having these hallucinations
in these dreams and he realizes he
figures out that there's one guy who's
being who's turning turning who's
talking to the feds and you can it makes
sense because that's what happens when
you put all this data together you go
wait a minute I don't donate right do
you like all easy case to solve to
choose a meth-head Brian well Brennan
love love is also comes with a lot of
denial of his blind love is blind it
comes with a lot of denial
alright and whatever she was doing for
him she was doing for me I love that
girl and she was good she was [ __ ] oh
good real frail dome no yep tracked my
phone she was an amazing girl and in a
lot of ways some of the best some of the
best poonanny yeah I said poonanny why
cuz I grew up in Jamaica who now are the
best some of the best bull nany some of
the some of the best porn on there they
don't say that - ah wow that's not why
Kimbrough quiet to me watch your mouth
someone up best someone up there spoon
on e blah blah blah
some of the best porn unless there is
why would she only do when she was high
on
and just quite a motherless son his son
to be because the poor Nana was in mum
brain
and that was all cloudy I was cloudy I
couldn't I couldn't think straight I
couldn't think straight
Pinal is not Jamaican bro I know my
brand
alright alright man sorry bro
alright alright this is a little memory
poon there's a painful memory I need you
give me some so I go one love to food
and this is a weird thing uh I hear just
uh I hear like this weird I can't make
the noise and I look and I and I look
close and I see a bunch of baby possums
a bunch of baby possums and I love a
puzzle yeah and the mom wasn't around so
I don't know what I did but I they were
in a they were in a dis is such a weird
story they were in a a box
somebody put them in a box the possums
yeah okay okay the box up and I brought
it home to my to the method yeah yeah
because my dogs like what the pablor you
know you know my dogs are jumping I
might get now okay get there and I go
like this I go something about the
possums I go this is a sign don't ask me
why I go she was with that guy those
possums are talking to me I go well were
you high too
I may as well been I put on down the
bread okay - what alright go on but not
in a cradle no no Craig Thomas [ __ ]
but not now so you go in there with the
box not like that she balls deep look at
her and I go like this
nope I go I'm gonna ask you this again
did you [ __ ] are you holding the box of
awesome now she's all come and
discombobulated right oh that's so cute
I go yeah [ __ ] these possums right now I
go [ __ ] these possums cuz I'll drown
them Oh Jesse now let me ask you a
question
did you or did you not thought she goes
no I go okay I understand well we'll
find out tomorrow she goes what do you
turn around I go well it burns when I
pee just took a piss
I'm sure it's nothing but I'm sure we'll
be fine
I was bluffing and she goes I feel sick
I go I know has she been gone what she
says you've been gone I said now I'm
gonna take peace I'm gonna drive these
possums into your stupid face nobody I
go no you're gonna say beater with the
pauses III made her eat all the possums
live I forced him down her meth throat
and I put some salt and pepper on them
I'm not a total monster we're her teeth
all jacked up I but I I said I'm gonna
drive these possums to the animal
shelter was night time so I said the
Animal Hospital yeah cuz they and when I
get back you need to be out of my house
oh damn does she leave yeah that was the
final straw she left the meth was the
Nano snot it was not the final straw
Brent and I had to drag it out much
longer
Oh prepare another three years I assume
let's go a year don't be so don't be so
unforgiving such a debbie downer yeah
because Maddie rules man it rules the
massage Jamaican word good money no look
up poonanny
damn it where is the original Tina honey
yeah I think it's from Jamaica it's not
man you don't know I thought putting
that banana doesn't work there
have you heard whatever
it's a Jamaican yeah man no it's
Jamaican Creole punani
second guess which may come from the
Rajput nanny yeah man
I love it oh man although I think the
urban dictionary should get the original
word punani open air was used in India
Kama Sutra to come a sex organ there you
go it's India well that's urban bush
there's part of the urban look Indian
labor we used to build roads in Jamaica
although we can during the 1930s and 40s
and 50s so a lot of the indian slang
made its way into the Jamaican
vernacular remember that they they sort
of legend it's not enough Indian and
then have you been stuck you know my
room
in college with Jamaican and when they
would get to talking to make me crazy
when they give you talking to each other
you would not understand a goddamn that
stuff it's incredible it is it cool they
start talking it's incredible say they
that's musical it is incredibly naked a
Jamaicans are fun I had some good times
Jamaicans are I worked with Jamaicans -
Jamaicans are a blast I love them never
met it how about this not many men are
gonna enlighten yeah they let a mean
Jamaica great I've never met him in red
wine either yeah I believe it or
Australian don't surf on an on a
Hawaiian wave because you get beaten up
not if you're Brendan Schaub but if
you're cool I'm surfing my tail off out
there they even took me to a local spa
you're at the size of a sea lion I look
like your size of a sea lion
here's a completely closed I know
they're friendly man yeah I know you can
go out there too right but nobody wants
to fight you in the sand those boys
would I mean there's some tough ones um
how was your weekend well I was in
Minnesota the ticket site was just
apologized to you guys because we still
sold well but we would have sold out but
the people were when they would go to
the website that got kicked out so
people thought it was sold out already
I'm gonna get tickets it was a bummer it
was a real problem but I had a good time
did you stroll them all I was secretly
hoping some of the Hells Angels will
show up mmm
[Music]
did you stroll them all at all I
strolled them on huge right it's huge
I've been there remember maybe six times
but all that's true so I know that mom
you don't have don't hey hey hey hey hey
keep your creative laughs I was high all
the time just highest job no attic this
what this is the final [ __ ] strong
just waste away to nothing
no and it's looking skinnier than Brian
it's so weird you know he used to be dry
well friend like a giant elephant you
ever see a skinny elephant just selling
big joints it's depressing um do you
want it around them all yeah you know
there's not a store I want anything from
in that in that they're all the same
think of socks think of every mall
you've ever been to then just combine it
in masses and it's just seven stories
that'll roll
coaster at Legoland Legoland and add a
new query and go karting yeah fun now
the one in Edmonton has a shooting range
well I'm going down there
yeah they got a lot of guns really
mm-hmm
I went and squeezed off couple rounds
here's what I worry about in the
shooting wrong
somebody's gonna turn the gun on the
rest of us
oh well that happened before that's how
the guy the American sniper died so
that's right that's right
um Minnesota though you went from New
Orleans Minnesota yeah it was fine are
you done shooting or no I have to fly
tomorrow said there it is Minnesota was
nice though I want to compliment you on
your shoes well thanks I never I usually
have a problem with your shoes those are
some beautiful sky blue Louie Vuitton
denim denim denim Louie V those are
denim Lou V's I know hard to get I hear
these puppies are hard to get do they
support your foot extra well yeah
they're pretty nice do they massage it
no I wish they did I'll tell you what I
did I say when I bought it to you at the
at the Mall of America what my back is
kind of hurting as I'm strolling the
mall cuz you know I run it hard and I'm
an old man and my back is a bit like
it's like an old meat right you should
have went the Brookstone send the
massage to the whole place thank you
thank you because you just you just got
to what I'm saying
I walked by Brookstone like oh you know
what they got you you know what I got
them yes about that big yeah oh my god
hold on that's so funny gotcha
I sit in the chair like oh this is
amazing and the guy goes yeah why don't
you try this dude I went I'll buy it
the minute it hit my neck I went I'll
buy it it's cool and I had him pack it
up controller Senate yes I probably got
you how did you pocket now cuz you
hustle now [ __ ] night I do this thing
it's a hustle I thought for the hustle
I thought huge a massage chair and he's
doing me those things are six grand
sleek um by ever tried one of these I
went sure half thank you I'll stay here
for another 30 minutes
oh I stayed there anyway they're nice
though they're nice so my life is gonna
change so if you guys noticed that I'm a
lot looser that my neck doesn't move
like old meat it's because of all the
testosterone I mean it's because of the
massager I'm taking those are nice
though
I'll give you that but they did get you
that's how they get you thank you no
one's buying this goddamn massage chairs
like six grand yeah
like oh not as good but just as God got
it uh-huh uh-huh you know I've been
doing lady 4 workouts and I've telling
Jim my friends were making fun of me I
did stop doing the first rabbit jump in
the classes you have regular classes
really do you wear pink sneakers or what
goes on with that no I don't care that's
awesome have you ever done what you guys
talk afterwards about your emotional
yeah where you how you feel I make so
many more friends is that great
I made something for Fred I told my wife
I was gonna tell this story because
she's a woman yeah and sometimes she
tells me stories that just go no or no
ending and I I just I start laughing
it's because that was a bad story right
and this was the story she told me as I
got she goes so you know the spiders
that jump but they're not big on wolf
spiders cuz yeah but this smaller I go
okay sure they're small so I saw one in
the sink and then I picked it up I put
it on a thing and I put it outside and
then the next day I'm like looking at
the painting of the jockeys and he's
there and he's like hello I was like I
was like oh my god because I'm here I'm
back and I was like no way and I was
like oh my god and that and then she
there was a pause and he goes I mean it
probably wasn't the same spider but like
still Amanda are you 40 I'm making a
protein shake and I just started I was a
bad story right yeah well it was I love
you but you do want up or with another
terrible story my wife tell your ghost
er my saving grace funniest [ __ ] she's
got a great sense of humor at the same
time you're gonna fighters not me so
you're gonna tell you some stuff on the
podcast what's that I told her I had to
tell that story because like if you and
I tell a story that goes nowhere it's
like I don't do it I used to well I
don't know the respect now if that if
the if close friends tell me a story you
know what I do now to is I'll be on the
phone like sometimes I reagent tells
long stories or have friends tell long
stories yeah I'll just hang up the phone
I'm gonna milk then I'll take your bad
area call you back I've done it I've
done it man that to you okay oh yeah
I'll go do you didn't want in your do
not click it's so crowded it's so nice
yeah it feels nice
yeah yeah was like this this weekend uh
Joe's cousin had a baby shower I'm
already exhausted oh yeah well it was
two hours away my own throat well it's
two hours away
wait so you had to go to the baby shower
yeah it's there she goes I don't get
like you wanted you don't like to go on
these things I don't well because I
travel so much when I do have some time
um I just want to be home it's not that
man not forget to pack t up will you
type tiger then so it's four hours total
driving time we might as well drove to
[ __ ] teal why it's a good time they
get there and it's so busy at these baby
showers you have time to talk to them
because there's a million people know so
it's just me hanging out with Joe and
Tiger the entire time yeah I don't make
sense to me yeah there was a school my
children are in elementary school and
there was a school party with the
parents threw a party and I didn't go
because I would rather throw a bunch of
thumbtacks on the ground and roll back
and forth on the thumbtacks then go to a
party with the parents of my children's
know that it's tough so don't care oh I
got an email from my son's class so that
this guy goes I don't know how they got
my email and stuff apparently email and
he goes bro throwing on all dad's
barbeque Sunday just the dad to my right
we need this bring a six-pack any
Pilsner you want well hang by the pool
we'll have guy time just the email
pissed me off
just the email on I went well now what I
have to get pity on my son right I see
the things to be awkward you can't
pretend I didn't see it of course
definitely saw ideas give you guys in
Philly thumbs up guys oh man's nothing
I'd rather do Sunday then recap my life
with paintballs is there ping-pong I got
seconds but when you don't know people
it's like sweetie bit up to it yeah man
yeah people just need connection but I
do that with my friends I've known yeah
me too
friends I don't talk to you enough yeah
but who's hard for me to see enough also
you and I like we do this podcast that's
a lot of hanging out we don't like I
don't need to hang we check in and stuff
like that it's like unless there's an
that's how guys are I think that really
is how guys are right I mean you you
need n it's fun to hang out and laugh
and stuff but you know [ __ ] your friends
so I did or I saw this show on Vice
called hunting Isis not hunting Hitler
hunting Isis is some crazy [ __ ] treati
please don't cut from the mic so I'm
sure you can bring up a [ __ ] snippet
of it chin but check this out these are
due to surge prior in the military they
get done they go home like we have
nothing to do so they just on their own
dime fly in to fight Isis for
mercenaries the kind of but they're not
like they're not special forces guys
they're like regular dudes they don't
get paid there's no US government
backing nothing they fight I forget what
they line up with the pressure guy yes
oh yeah so there's fighting Isis on Vice
and there's hunting Isis on history
fighting Isis on Vice this do you're on
the right one right here so they come in
history so they hang it all no it's not
history it's vice good the vice one so
the by believe the press murga are the
Kurdish fighting force the Kurds are bad
monster Kurdish yeah and they've
actually pushed them back yeah the curse
oh these guys help out but man there's a
there's a reason why they go on tours
right and can't say that long because
the guy who's the medic he's I dude I
help so many people and I have no one to
talk to and he goes you're [ __ ] up
from it because he's been there for
forever yeah that day a lot of guys need
to stay close to that flame they got
addicted to it that's what they said
they said they're chasing the tail of
you know that dragon and they've just
been out there forever and they go how
much pay goes no pay life is about money
I do it because you know I [ __ ] hate
ice so watch this crazy oh this is HBO
it's vice though nope sure that's like
the TV show it might be history right no
be nice
HBO because well there's a segment on
they have the Shawn HBO not anymore I
don't think but let's just show on Vice
I'm vice land there you go hunting Isis
junsu out there that's them I had heard
the stories I knew that Isis was evil
but you can never really understand the
brutality that they're capable of until
you see it with your own eyes what
brought me here adventure adrenaline but
the end i think is gonna be guilt
volunteer that comes here actually works
my mom dad they don't exactly know that
I'm here right now I think I'm
backpacking in Asia there's nothing I
would do to get back over there like a
massage by a sniper so once you
experience combat the adrenaline rush is
like nothing you'll experience anywhere
it's got me hooked I guess crazy right
that's a good show I'll be watching that
yeah saw the first episode last night
it's a damn good show yeah man I think
it's crazy cuz they don't have any
support from the from the US military
anything like that they're fighting on
the other side
it's crazy [ __ ] yeah super entertaining
I just can't right they're just good
dudes obviously they're trying to fill
some void because one came back to
America is that guys if y'all I say
let's try and do this you know nothing
really picked up and my friend told me
about this and then the way they get in
there because remember they can't go in
a traditional way yeah they have to be
like [ __ ] smuggled in to get there so
Isis then get a hold of them so for my
very limited experience doing stand-up
in in 2007 in Afghanistan I was I would
when you're in a war zone there are
people who were military and they come
back to help facilitate things in a
non-military capacity right so they'll
be with the locals and I'll help you
they said so guys that are organizing us
that teach us how to do stuff and so
they might be exited and the one one guy
was I never forgot this he was a dude
who had bullet holes he had I know what
those look like and he had them in his
leg in his arm and it looks like burn
marks round burn marks and I go oh those
are boom arm I go those are bullet yep
he got shot like
six times or something and I go Jesus
looks like a big caliber weapon he goes
now I wasn't too big that's why I'm
standing here and and I spent a lot of
time with him he was an ex we didn't
know what he was but I knew from the
other guys that he had been some kind of
a special forces guy who was clearly not
doing so well that there was nothing for
him on the civilian side so he'd come
right back and the other guy who was all
our handler who organized the USO had
been a recon marine and he was an
amazing man and he was he was in Vietnam
so he had and again he had he had
complete scars all over his legs from
getting shot by a naked he also tried
going back to benandsabine he said to me
he goes he explained to me that there
are a lot of those guys who come back
who just need to be close to the flame
then adrenaline the Quran like that
they've not been able to adjust to
civilian life so they come back and they
work for the Department of Defense in a
civilian capacity but at least they're
in a war zone with people that
understand them people that you know it
was really interesting man this so
there's a whole subculture of that as
well sure know when you get done think
about when you get done you're young man
and you know mid-20s and get done
fighting Isis and you get out and like
you get back to the real world like oh
go work in an office or go do this like
what what are you gonna talk to people
about they don't understand yet relate
to you you never feel more she'll have
that brother had I get it and I tell you
the Dove and I one time we're eating
breakfast and these dudes me and dove
the Duke comedians who are fascinated
with tough guys and this [ __ ] group
of men came in and you could see by the
way they were they were organized when
they sat down how organized they were
but the first thing Devin Aizen does
what their traps and they didn't look
like regular soldiers they just looked
like they were and [ __ ] crazy they
look like CrossFit athletes with beards
so we're like what the what do they do
and it was so obvious that they were
they were clearly an elite division of
Special Forces and stuff and when you
looked at it Dov and I went like this we
had to go and we're and Dov was like oh
hey
I want to hang out with these real men
that are you you there's something in
credit you can see there's something
incredibly I don't know exciting about
it when you feel like a true Spartan and
you're [ __ ] in sick shape and you
live this dangerous lifestyle right like
that [ __ ] cuz you have drinks and [ __ ]
them afterwards or we were their
concubines a we ended up cooking
everything would run so fast for me you
know I do what nothing's better for
those grouper men no other man I come up
and talk let me add some high-heeled
sneakers and a [ __ ] miniskirt and we
had a great time and I had to shave my
body down yeah man that's that's that's
a that's that Hurt Locker [ __ ] look at
these guys yeah that's crazy man is ice
to still be like we've kind of limited
them right yeah we've taken out all the
main things and paid a price yeah I mean
obviously there's still [ __ ] out
there but they're not as big of deal
right they've been they've been crippled
yeah I was part that's crazy I want to
see that that's a super interesting
speaking of violence we got some fights
coming up this weekend yep you see 225
we got Whitaker Romero yeah what you
just found out about yep well I know
they were fight that is TV my question
is III who do you have for that fight
well do you tell me man I'd spent two
hours breaking I got I got Romero really
her I got Romero because as great as
Whitaker looked I think Whitaker's
coming off a long layoff Mills that's
significant
I think Romero's coming off a huge win
over alcohol I was so impressed with
Romero's defense his ability to kind of
stay just the edge of the pocket and
catch almost catch Luke's punches took
some damage to the knee to the leg so if
I'm Whitaker I'm gonna [ __ ] hammer
that leg he can kick he can kick and
Whitaker is every bit as strong and as
fast as rock hold heat or fall faster
knuckle he's faster yeah I love you
stronger yes sir but I don't know if
there's anybody more explosive than
Romero he can just unload in that split
second he tried it last time but I'm
gonna go with Romero just because of
momentum momentum that's fair the only
thing is to is if you're a robert
whittaker fan minute Robert Robert
Whittaker beat ya'll Romero up with one
leg he did and avoided the takedown
you had one leg in that fight and still
beat him so now you have a long left he
fully healthy and you get both legs yeah
and your male is not getting better he's
getting old right right well time is not
on his side
no it's on whitaker side so I'll go
Whitaker I think he stops him this time
though really I think TKO third fourth
Wow
yeah based on fighting him the same way
or no I just think Whitaker is that good
I think Whitaker is he's a real [ __ ]
champ man I think you're with Yoel you
know he does he is explosive I think you
know with Rockwell Rockhold he hasn't
been the same Ronald so where everyone's
all high on you don't remember after we
did Rockville but that's not though that
rock cold wasn't the same rock called
were used to seen I think he's lost his
confidence a little bit I think you see
I thought it was really good I didn't
think Luke looked like his kicks were
landing on that leg I thought his
punching was so crisp I just I just
thought that Romero was so good at just
standing on the edge of that pocket that
measuring that distance so Luke would
throw and he just almost catch those
shots book with that cross guard yeah I
don't think I think Whitaker gets it
done
yeah view is able to avoid the takedown
with one leg you write him both I think
finishes them really I mean I would be
surprised for y'all rent wins I just got
Whitaker so I got Romero now we got Kobe
called Kobe Covington Rafael dos Anjos
we've seen what I think Raphael and 170
is undefeated so far right correct a
beast
a very a multi-dimensional fighter the
only thing I have the only question I
have is koko fees MMA wrestling better
than Rafael dos Anjos his wrestling's
better but I you know his striking and
setups aren't better and his jiu-jitsu
is not better yeah if you're Kobe
commenting fan that can be a worst
matchup for him but if Kobe were to win
it would be you know huge a decision
definitely a decision yeah he's a rugged
dude but you you think he's let he's not
as de mentioned as no he's not as
well-versed as dosa that makes sense
hasn't fighting as long the Sun just is
amazing I'm gonna go with Rafal this I'm
just there yep um Holly Holm Megan
Anderson who did Megan Anderson fight
who was last year's didn't
this their first fight in the UFC she's
tall she's tall one with Australian he's
big yeah that's sexy girl uh-huh very
much um tats on the arms yep yep and
then Holly Holm happy was absolutely
last four out of five some suspect you
know the jury in to be yeah win but uh
I'm gonna go with it I'm Megan Anderson
on this one
I want Megan to yeah I think she's a big
strong
I think she's bigger than the Holly
isn't she because that weight don't have
the same striking as Holly though but
yeah that arlovski tied to a Musa fights
fun doing it I don't know that guy I
think it's M fights him first-round
knockouts oh he's big oh this guy he
remember yeah he does that dance
that's a Samoan man yes I just known as
they get oh yeah it's from New Zealand
oh yeah always Maori that yeah yeah well
well I need a rugby player there you go
enjoy that enjoy those legs in that
power not a fun fight for loss ski what
a warrior Alaska is though yeah I'm
gonna go with the Youngblood yeah me too
the young the Youngblood
and then you to end it yes CM Punk Mike
Jackson I'm not that I'm just out to
break that fight down below the belt you
did I had to [ __ ] yeah I mean look
into it yeah tell me about my Jackson
what about him he's owned one that's -
Mickey Galt - he has some amateur
experience you know neither one of these
guys should have the only thing they
should be wearing your seeds if they
bought off the internet they neither one
should be there but it is what it is man
the prelims are not yeah I mean I don't
I'm not talking about that fight who
would you pick what I'm talking about
the UFC fight that's fair
so yeah I get it I'm talking about USC
fausto Rinker's blades now I'm
definitely going with Curtis blades are
you because I was cuz I watched him
train I met him I know and uh I was very
impressed with the way I was watching
spar and train I was like Jesus watch
over him spar sure haven't sure haven't
I was about to say I was about say
plays a giant man but I've seen Alistair
Overeem sad mad asters bigger yeah yeah
he's a giant man - I got Curtis Curtis
young young blood young blood and whose
great decision no not Cash's knockout
I believe he knocks out I think if
there's a finish it's over in knocking
him out I believe you could be right
baby
I believe Curtis plates either knocks
him out or takes him down and cams him
yeah he's the favorite you know yeah Oh
cardiac Italia and Carla Esparza well I
mean if Claudia wins should get the net
well she get a title shot against Rose
that's a great fight good fight though
right very good fight Arkin nobody you
know where I am I'm in Raleigh North
Carolina buddy after I shoot in New
Orleans on Wednesday I go to Raleigh
I'll be a good night so get your tickets
right now admire your schedule enough I
know it's been tough it's been the worst
it's been the worst I'll be honest with
you but it's almost done yeah after that
I got a Owyhee and then I'm gonna bring
it back wait wait so you get back from
Sunday and then when you go to Hawaii
Monday but we're doing the podcast you
missed it this week and then you miss
all the podcast makes me only one Monday
one day well Monday no I'm gonna win no
not so a afternoon I said it okay yeah
we're good
all right I'm good this weekend yeah hey
Jade is still fighting I'm sorry I just
saw that I know her I was only there how
much do you look like we I didn't even
tire and then he came back the other
Schad fine you got Rashad fighting you
know one fight pass
Joey Benavides love Joey
oh I wish I go with Joey coz I love him
I love Clay Guida I'm going with him I'm
going with shot
that's just emotional is the key revenge
in yeah since we're on this fight Kolby
Covington recently called out Joe Rogan
again and this is what he said just
because you do tech window doesn't mean
you can talk to the
of chaos and he wrote a bunch of other
stuff too what yeah I read your stuff
some of it will go through it yeah
please
all right quote his little mouth was
trying to run and say things when he
shouldn't have an opinion you've never
been in the Octagon you don't have any
experience fighting just because you do
these little tech hundo tournaments and
you can't even get first place in those
doesn't mean you can come talk to the
king of chaos aka the new welterweight
King on June 9th I got something to say
to him and I'm gonna say something to
him when I see him face to face and you
should come say something face to face
did yo what do you guys say you're not a
fighter
okay yeah I mean but it's smart of Coby
remember Kobe a title shot he's on a win
streak with B's cuz he does stuff like
this it's a brilliant move on his part
mark and wise to go after Joe Rogan the
untouchable yeah that has every name
another fighter he's gone after Joe
Rogan like this yeah I don't and now
he's again on the face of every [ __ ]
news outlet who's eating it up because
they know Rogan gets clicked so there
you go sure so it's another brilliant
marking move by Kobe Compton he's
theatricals not gonna touch Joe it's you
know does the other has Joe fought no
does Taekwondo count depends who you
talk to
right so it's you know Kobe he's doing a
good job trying to poke it choke the
bear yeah yeah and I think that I don't
think anybody disagrees that Joe is the
best at this job at calling fights as
good as he is I mean I don't have to get
better than that
I don't know and he's an excellent
commentator yeah excellent at explaining
what's going on and all that so that's
what he does that's his job so yes okay
he didn't fight in the Octagon that's
correct
that's correct and it is it's a it's a
smart two brilliant markets and smart
mom's always done this stuff I don't
know if he likes to play the heel yeah
any embrace is it wholehearted and
that's all he's doing he's pointing at a
point in his tribute to Joe now he's
going after our sacred cow yeah that's
very smart I don't agree with this but
it's smart I'll tell you this right now
Kobe Kobe
be if he puts a hand on my friend don't
hold us here firearms no no no I will
[ __ ] I'll come at you who another
Taekwondo guy Kobe get ready don't
comment I find a guy I happen to have
been boxing forth over three [ __ ]
years personal trainer Colby no wit no
I'm trying to CrossFit sometimes yeah
and I still practice my kicks on the bag
and you're thrice and I'll rub my
psoriasis all of your [ __ ] face what
else come at us bro and end wrestle
branch at Brendan Shaw I'm friends with
Brendan Schaub so if you [ __ ] hurt me
he'll get me he'll have my back right
maybe what depends off this what the
[ __ ] do a fan of Kobe - though I'm all
brave right now cuz you're behind me
what else you get in [ __ ]
alright Clay Matthews was doing a
charity softball game and it was a
teammate batting and it was just a freak
accident he actually broke his nose with
the ball you want to see this little
slick Harris you seen this be no home
right on the nose yep reconstructive no
surgery yeah no exactly a lot of pain
and he was he was leaking a little bit
but uh itself God cuz I was still being
on that ground right now but uh he just
damn let me see yet again Clay Matthews
that's ox different lottery season
that'll affect this football right you
could hear it now be alright
you got the whole crowds like ah got
right back up oh man hold Green Bay
Packers [ __ ] I gotta have fun you're
gonna get your nose packed I've had that
done the worst isn't that the worst
and those three days when you can't
breathe out of your [ __ ] mouth for
him and it's just you're missing
preseason shed and terrible it's just
stuff you don't need they don't need it
that's a good that's a freak out thing
bless my nose pretty good and we'll have
surgery once swelling subsides it could
have been much more serious could it
that's a big game well there's that guy
I saw on Instagram I got his eye kicked
out of his head did you see that oh I
saw that huh oh please fellas it's
terrible man dude he got his eye kicked
out buddy yes he got roundhouse kick to
the head and he has an eye rolling
around I was like this is all he comes
out of a thug it stop laughing about it
it's horrible you ready
I just sick [ __ ] I was like hi I'm like
that's a terrible kick hardcore I didn't
see it I didn't I don't know how this
happened where's the knife I'm so sorry
I started looking at right now
right there hits rolling that's his
[ __ ] I see it oh poor guy that was
his eye but you know it's not a real eye
it's always a glass yeah I think I did
beginning oh we had a fake got to begin
with
there's no way oh no like that's not a
fake either allow them to festive 100%
if you can't fight with a fake ID that's
what I think that's one of the reasons
why he might get in trouble for this -
maybe he are you sure I'm gonna I'll bet
online Oh Alan Alan Gray's glass eye
falls on a head kick oh I took a real
there would be stuff attached to it baby
yeah Oh glass side and gives it well
that's a glass eye that happenings gotta
suck so fight with a glass eye I mean
right poor guy he's a tough photo god
bless him hey Alan Alan Grant you're a
bad [ __ ] keep your eye on the
fire
Wow Brendan Brendan I don't like you
right now
I hear you stop laughing Brendan I can
see all your teeth right now you're
laughing so hard I'm sorry man you look
like a giant giraffe I'm sorry damn it
god no [ __ ] you guys I think I might
fight what's the worst can happen
your IQ kicked out he can't do it
anymore now all right well I'm sure
that's ain't unit somewhere how dare
that [ __ ] opponent kick is having a
fight with an eye where you can't see
that shot coming you keep your hand up
you can't you don't fight with one hi
kicked in that side of your head it came
from the others so he got kicked on the
side where he does have an eye all right
I'm sorry I asked you bastards both of
you a couple of horse laughs just horse
get giggling I just CT oh poor guy man
[ __ ] you know why'd you bring it up
Brian well why are you he's trying his
bad I didn't know it was funnier than
the movie The Hangover oh my god well I
thought it was gonna be like dangling
out like you know and I I like the
attachment all that [ __ ] it'd be
terrible
yeah well Cheers like it's so bad no
when I saw it I feel bad for the guy no
I feel bad for him for sure yeah
finally I think it's terrible what what
else you had Jim all right all right so
this is a picture of Serena and Venus
Williams with their the Pete with the
two girls that they played against in
doubles French Open against a Japanese
team have you seen them together no I'll
play this for you because if do you
don't one who what look at them together
so here they are hugging and they walk
over to them good game but size
difference good game uh what's with the
school that's crazy
what is it better fish right there and
they beat the piss out well yeah I mean
good luck return that surf oh my god
hello these are our avatars those are
the those the Serena had to pull out
she's supposed to look I need the house
Sharapova
she had to pull out cuz of a peck injury
Federer thing said she might be the
greatest ever
yeah I mean it's hard argue that's so
funny
how funny is that what did they beat him
a thousand two nothing I don't know what
the points is but I didn't play
are they Batman badminton players I mean
that's crazy okay but then they're
they're really tall girls anyways right
not really Serena is not that tall
Serena is about five eight I stood next
to her I might even be shorter
now Venus is Venus is six - I think okay
fine
that's actually pretty tall enough for a
girl and then Venus 596 one out there
she's I am think she's five nine because
I'm she's not small be fun not other two
Serena's I would say I would say yeah
five nine and six but yeah I'm still one
six six one there big man big girls
they're [ __ ] oh yeah yeah oh you know
Sharapova six one sure Pope is a very
big a lot of those women are large and
strong I saw the d1 Pepperdine team the
girls come in yeah she's six - I'm sorry
I saw the d1 Pepperdine team come in
they were all just majestic tall women
big big framed in everything tennis is
you know it's very common to see six
foot four men and you know six foot plus
women what does she had ten hour all
right do you know this bar in Denver not
that yeah this is one mm-hmm
also this is crazy all right so FBI
agent was doing a dance and did a
backflip his gun came out and this is at
fires and it fires and he hit someone
Zoe a shot phone like this bar here yes
Hill high spirits okay that's quit this
FPS your gun go off you'll see it I'll
show you the fuse yeah pop and he qicang
kind of dance and does the back for me -
got my gun - so it didn't even go off
with the gun hitting it was when he
picked up his must hit the trigger yep
so I'll show you the club nightclub is
it videos from Denver look at him Jack
look at him though I'm not mad in the
tightest jeans Oh
shot a dude in the legs didn't even know
went off he goes my bad poor guy didn't
know it went off no I think he knew no
he didn't no no I don't think he's hit
anybody that's crazy huh but if it's so
that you're not gonna loan the baby here
without noise and stuff guy idea
obviously they know why he went oh sorry
like this huh
I kinda feel like that happened they had
no idea how to react so I don't think
should lose his job that's my thing is
how good of an FBI agent is if he's a
badass so he's having a little fun get
me to shoot him yeah yeah and the guy he
like in the lower leg picks it up right
away put it in and it just one I'm gonna
pick up and shot somebody but yeah yeah
that's different that's like a douche
Mike you blow fun well he looks stupid
sorry had to get the attention away oh
look over there kaduche weakly what
happened your leg I'm not mad as dance
moves though no there's a set of cheeks
I'm as well doesn't actually feel bad
for the guy Oh a cheek cheeks yeah and I
like that he can do a backflip he's a
look at him go hey and when they go
white boy go white boys out yeah yeah
yes yeah that's really weird
it went off almost when he touched the
gun yeah that's so weird
accidentally hit that yeah I don't know
I don't know how that works we'd have to
have a ballistic guy coming here how
does that work watch if you look at the
reactions to the people you could tell
they know the gun when I got in the
hat's the fun watch boom then he runs
yeah sure he had no idea what how to
react he's like oh [ __ ] oh you got
embarrassed and some guy hit that
[ __ ] leg Lisa's just lycée anyone in
the face yeah
well sketch in let's take a look oh did
you even know that there was a reboot a
remake of the crow do us one crow hell
yes Lee Sun and Bruce Lee son died on it
yeah for that person yep
they say it's cursed and so Jason Momoa
was supposed to play it oh well no no
five weeks before they started shooting
they had to back out of why I guess Sony
pulled the plug on the money all the
funding to do it so damn sure would be
sick there's like a teaser with him and
damn look at that he's such a badass
that's [ __ ] gnarly they pulled the
plug on it so cool-looking man Danny
would have been perfect I've been so
sick you ever seen him in person I was
doing Conan I saw him in a t-shirt and I
actually walked up to him because
everybody's looking at him everybody's
like who is that guy he's so incredible
looking so he's so cool-looking and I
and everyone's talking about him we
weren't I think some famous actors at
the table at the time you know we're che
and this restaurant I walked out to and
I go bro what do you do man he was so
nice he was I'm an actor I go what's
your nationality like what you look
unbelief art talking ID he was in a
white t-shirt he was so big and handsome
and but cool-looking and then we we
dated you've got a chill Ellen you
should know come on Joe how the chase of
the law is a very intimate area that was
when he was younger
what's his Aquaman movie come out that
was his big one I haven't heard anything
about it though
Aquaman and he's on the frontier series
on Netflix
yeah dad that been cool though I rolled
my hair long now you should try that do
you think so later this year December
21st
Amber Heard Willem Dafoe who I love
later this year he said got to somehow
how old is he 17 but cheese I bet you
he's 40 38 still young very young yeah
no young just again started dude no [ __ ]
let's get chin all right do you remember
that thing that happened where two gay
guys wanted to get a wedding cake and
then the person that they asked them yep
to built to make it said they didn't
want to do it because their religious
beliefs and they sue them well the court
is in favor of the Baker who refused to
make them the wedding cake Yeah right
right yes right it's his own private
business I think what that does is just
you know if you don't want to make them
a cake you there are other businesses
you let the marketplace work there are
other businesses that go oh he doesn't
want oh you didn't want your business
I'll take your business most of them
will take the business so you're being
alienated let them do or you're gonna
have your niche would be right yeah
that's right forget games and the spot
cakes only from them sure it's called
freedom of expression
Susan's America Miss America well and I
understand that too but they think they
were gonna win them oh it's in Colorado
well you know it's discrimination right
so are those the bakers on the left yeah
no no with that guy's hair you know he
looks like he looks like he looks like
you if you had me and Tom Segar looks
like you with my friend looks like mean
Tom so does it looks like you and Tom
for a cigarette
he's got your hair only his dye job
where he got a gray white went well and
he looks exactly like Brendan and you're
like don't like maker on the right I
look like a crotchety okay yeah you do I
look like a crotchety bigoted old buddy
is better in here he doesn't her hair
holy that might be me or his hands so
white for a powder
they're full of I see Lauer that's
powder flour Oh actually he looks like
he has empathy go yeah he definitely
does he lost pigmentation when you lose
pigmentation it makes you anti-gay I'm
sorry I was just confused who was making
the cake in that picture
that's hilarity dude if you dated a man
that's who you should date because the
big beer know the other guy well looks
like unions yeah but you like yourself
so you guys can make out you vain
[ __ ] like yes man good Jim
look at that hair the Samantha because
hair makes me want to bully him not
because he's gay just cuz his hairs all
in his head cinch students if you have
to be Samantha be on her show she said
she called Ivanka Trump a feckless [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah but they bleeped it out on the show
so I guess it was just oh yeah okay
she's not losing her job though but
advertisers did pull some yeah
very poor taste isn't very poor taste it
was gross people are demanding that she
that she should lose her job like
Roseanne and well there's it there's
definitely a double standard I mean I
think why they're built I think the
leftist it tends to be way more way more
that they don't they're not as the
consistent but you know is it because
one's a racist tweet though and that a
little differently probably I just think
that was a little more I was pretty I
think I think they're both ill-will I
think it both terrible yeah it's not
even that creative or funny it's not
funny in the any facet but once like
racism you have a you have a history of
being racist so I think it's a little
different you know I was saying that I
was saying somebody was saying well
Roseanne swears she didn't know she was
black okay cool fine you know what I'll
even give you that take it you want that
I won't do that
I don't matter I don't give you I don't
care you wanted me to give you the
advance and now I think there are two
ways to look at that one is this is not
the first time right you do this all the
time right doesn't your mo right yeah so
if you're gonna do that in this
environment there's no one that doesn't
know in this business then if you're
gonna do that you're gonna pay a very
steep price so what do you want so what
do we do now
what do you what do you want to do just
I guess it sounds supposed to me today
on the keeping the show but without
Roseanne okay I make about the daughters
what I heard all right well by the way
you pay a very very steep price for that
in this marketplace we all know that so
I I don't know what else to say and I do
think I do think that there is there's
got to be a little bit of a difference
when you are deliberately racist in this
environment maybe if you say something
that is racist right if you say
something that could be if you compare a
black person to an ape in this case you
know that has a long history man you're
gonna pay a price I don't buy that she
didn't know she had any african-american
descent because if you want to really
like be mean spared so on you'd go after
their race right and also when would you
just reference monkey in regards to a
person well and also you know the other
the other possibility and again it
doesn't matter but the other possibility
that I actually believe is I don't think
Roseanne is dealing with a full deck I
think she suffers from a formidable
illness
I think she's Otto
lot of antidepressants and other drugs
which she says right it that's fine I
did the fact the matter is I still don't
know what to do with that remark right I
still got a sensor I don't think you've
my free pass right a lot of people are
mentally that's are handicapped or
mentally ill and they're not racist
well no it's like this and I got you
also have the you also clear mine enough
to log into your phone no misspellings
you know like the grammar is perfect
everything's good good ambient doesn't
make you racist also we on ambient all
the previous times you've done stuff
like this the other thing is everybody
in this world says or thinks five things
that for whatever reason we get them
fired five times an hour we human beings
have all kinds of inappropriate thoughts
and things like that but it's like my
buddy said I've driven buzzed and a lot
of people who are good people have
driven buzzed knew better probably got
in the car when they were just a little
bit over the line but I'll make it home
cuz I'm gonna drive slow whatever cool
you got away with it if you get caught
you could lose your license go to jail
or worse kill somebody so if you get
caught I know that it's the first time
you've done it I know you're having a
tough time your whole family died in the
fire at the end of the day you got to
pay the price and that's how I look at
it yeah right
you got you got caught you got caught
now and I do think there's a little bit
difference between samman I don't know I
don't like what Samantha bee said but I
do think you're right I think there is a
little bit of a difference isn't there
like Samantha bee is kind of going I
think I think Samantha bee should like
have some repercussions I don't think
you should lose your job when there's
racism like we just can't have any of
that it's more sensitive it's we can't
yeah what Jen yeah all right moving on
and both apart you know she apologized
and it's all [ __ ] up you say too much
you know you were talking about this too
when you have that much content that you
have to fill all the time you're gonna
cross a line Jordan Peterson there's no
B there's difference so when I say that
I you know like when I when I had those
comments about Fox I made those counts
and I'm trying to fill in you know
whatever nine hours of content and stuff
like that but this is just loosey goosey
when it did you remember they write this
stuff yeah
so she someone wrote that they approved
it shot it retake it and all in
agreeance agreed that that was okay too
yeah that's that's the diff that's
that's God listen what's a very good
point that doesn't work that's a good
point that's a good point and by the way
yeah you're right there's a whole team
that greenlit right and that and that
was classless it was classless is
holding a chart her child up and you got
to do that like what else did she say
about it because as mad as you aren't
Samantha B should also be met the entire
staff that worked because yeah remember
those things there's a process that yes
there she do for bias there's a process
that goes through like I'm below the
belt if I had something in it so let's
say I did my Fox take on below the belt
it wouldn't make it to the floor yeah I
give them my take on the a block they go
okay okay we can do this what do you
think about this how about if you your
thoughts on this and if I if there's
something in there like well no you
can't say that because of this all that
makes sense right sing [ __ ] here she
she's not going up but I wanted to say
something I wanted to say what's what
Samantha be said okay so listen to this
full-frontal you know Ivanka Trump
that's a beautiful photo of you and your
child but let me just say one mother to
another do something about your dad's
immigration practices you feckless [ __ ]
now watch this put on something tight
and low-cut and tell your father to
[ __ ] stop it tell him it was an Obama
thing and see how it goes okay and then
she added something else which was she
also added that he'll listen to you
yeah was this yeah because you do that
so and they had to make sure so so just
so you know so so anybody who says
anything sexist anybody who says any
sexist it loses their job of Europe if
you're a little guy said that right your
[ __ ] what if Jimmy Fallon said you're
[ __ ]
game over [ __ ] game over right so you
guys all this so the left seems to be
super on edge about anything that a man
says or anybody says on the right if
it's demeaning to women and you're
saying put on something low-cut so
you're you're saying do that to your own
father and and it'll turn him on so
you're talking you're implying his his
father
your father's attracted to you and
you're calling us back those [ __ ] she
all she did was post a really sweet
picture of her and her child and she has
nothing Ivanka Trump has nothing to do
with his dad's immigration
policies and the immigration is a very
complicated issue he's against illegal
immigration okay and there's there's a
there's an argument he made against
illegal immigration so [ __ ] [ __ ]
Samantha B as well [ __ ] her too and
there should be outraged about that too
but there's not there's [ __ ] not
everybody's quiet about it because
everybody's two-faced so to me that's
offensive when you do that it's
offensive what happened to being
offensive to women what happened all
that where is that why are we why are
people so quiet about a Samantha bee
they kind of are you know you're
fretless cabron well as faculties a
feckless not freckly
others you guys know what that was
before feckless no you know cuz I didn't
know feckless feckless look at me all
the time feckless means like it means no
good I think it means no but you in me
is like ditzy that's the equivalent like
ditzy no so it no it means you're like
without fact meetings without freckles
freckles you put means you're without
effect you're effect less Brian doesn't
know I had to look it up too so it means
lacking initiative or strength character
irresponsible without one without
freckles lacking initiative or strength
of character one without character in
freckles yeah okay Cara alright the next
one is hold on this is in Utah a dog a
husky killed over 30 around 30 animals
next-door neighbors channels chickens so
the guy that had the house or the people
who had the house they did a little type
of petting zoo for kids with
disabilities
so this husky went into the back and
then just killed just to kill not to eat
or anything so I'll list you the number
of the animals here so two rabbits two
ducks
five chickens turn dog go goose yeah
being da standard peanut yeah yeah
that's being a dog so how do you how do
you get in there oh it just snuck out of
the house somehow yeah
ladies not ever tell you sorry about
when Joe Rogan and I went and bought I
bought myself a fighting pitbull yeah
the ad said just out of the box had my
friend watching on his farm my friend
called me I'm goes your dog's not with
us anymore I go what he goes yeah your
[ __ ] dog bam bam ain't with us
anymore what I go what do you mean he
goes well I felt this is [ __ ] up he
goes I don't know why I'm laughing this
is not funny cuz I found my cat's head
on my [ __ ] front stoop so he killed
my cats man he killed two of my goats he
[ __ ] had he had a hold of my
neighbor's calf had hold he had he bit
that calf right where the hind haunts
and the belly meats hanging off it the
golden retriever came out bark and a
German Shepherd came out barking him he
broked out he broke that dog's both that
dog's [ __ ] front legs stroke his
growth his front legs and then he came
back on that [ __ ] cow and he goes and
that was your [ __ ] fighting pit ball
cuz he gained up his balls dropped and
he went crazy and I shot that [ __ ]
dog he's a farmer my buddies and
farming's I shot that dog so you want to
visit his bones you go ahead you when I
went to his farm I went I went and
visited BAM Bam's bones because he
didn't even bury that dog he's a scream
he was so [ __ ] angry I was like sorry
and I had to pay for two goats I had to
pay the neighbors cow had to be put down
as long as a cab Hey yep and his dog
made it his dog why was the people at
the South Gate trouble why did the
people go the phone cuz I was in LA and
I went back to New York for a while I
went back for nine months to do to do to
work and and do stand-up and so I had my
buddy keep my dog ban bad it was a young
dog I knew there's a game bred pitbull
yeah I had him stand I said to him I go
Tony I think this dog's game bred so be
cool man he's a skinny rangy
[ __ ] but he's bred to fight so
you gotta keep him on a leash nothing
isn't now I know dogs I got a bunch of
dogs it's fine
well then he dropped him on a farm one
day my dog decided I'm a pitbull once
his balls dropped and he was like I'm
gonna kill everything raises Christ yeah
hmm sorry people who love dogs but
I mean what can you do yeah do you want
to go over the bare-knuckle stuff you
care about that all right
know what the Bears like a bare-knuckle
boxing thing that happened over the
weekend and we're Rico Rodriguez in
old-school UFC fighter Joey Beltran
Rodriguez he's he said like how old is
Rican super old 50 oh no no he was that
he was at MIT for say early 40s but
already he was that he was uh Rico
Rodriguez was a model and he was a dog
NC Double A champion Abu Dhabi champion
was on 24 th am worrying about the
different guy that's all but no they'd
they'd it's he's like he didn't bring my
suave you never asked him back I'm
thinking about [ __ ] okay I'm thinking
about different guys but this guy was
also considered good looking model ish
to went back in the day yeah old-school
here's this have you guys seen this two
fighters and this is in Brazil after the
ref broke it up they kept fighting what
I'll just show it because it's more
testimony to watch so this guy hasn't
been the leg lock so they break up the
fight
and then as he turns around the rough
turns around they go at it again they
try punching and then even still just
doing a good job guys are small guys
kicking on and bone anyhow there's that
and they're both disqualified
where are you all out of chrome that's
general what oh how about this a pilot
whale died in Thailand after swallowing
17 pounds of plastic [ __ ] pilot whale
you can't swallow plastic
we need more pilot whales on the service
of course we do what's a pilot whale I
never know what they thankfully cons I
don't you when you see one there's a
sweat when people draw whales what they
draw their those but they don't know the
name of them that's so funny these
little guys oh they almost look like
[ __ ] dolphins
yeah cutie [ __ ] sorry what a bummer I
love whales
I love pilot whales are cute they're a
cute way all right yeah big Bobby heads
one is a pet they look like they alien I
know oh I want a coochie coohcie them
under their chin they're cute yeah they
look just like dolphins it delicious too
ponzu sauce what what what I say I'd eat
a pilot whale right now I'm starving for
the mercury don't do it you hungry
yeah you let us get a chance at it I got
a lot more um just getting this I
thought you ran out cuz fight once saw
not what else yet well I don't know if
this is a big deal you guys all that's
how jeff monson
remember old school Jeff Manto all tats
so Putin grant him Russian citizenship
pretty cool Wow he does a lot for
Russian Samara here's an anarchy
anarchist guy huh huh you ever seen a
class picture when he was uh there's a
riot and he's there in riot gear and
there's like four like ant
riot officers surrounding him and he's
just a throughout he's like this he's
yeah
I was a great iconic picture yeah the
future school is named I'm sure Jeff
Monson or riot I guarantee it'll pop up
right away if Boonton crash everybody I
would yeah I'm laughing like it's
[ __ ] Randy Couture chiyan you gotta
as one of these that's it
like he was tattoos I mean he's right
there what he was always like he's a
super anti-government yeah that one is
back like you guys should keep zoom in
on them yeah that looks like oh yeah it
looks like the gospel isn't the famous
Vietnamese in capitalism that's a guy
shoot another one's head off no well
that's a famous that's from a famous
South Vietnamese a picture answer yet
those SWAT team guys were like uh we
need backup look at that neck well he
was a monster yeah he was a great
wrestler I believe I don't exactly I'm I
don't grappler Jiu Jitsu but wasn't he
an NC double-a I don't the Olympic
wrestler no like he was pleased look
that up Chung yeah I think he was not a
national champion phenomenal he wrestled
but his jiu-jitsu was phenomenal he's
the north/south choke grapplers
conference conference well he won a
bunch of chances yeah he was that was
that pac-10 champion for he also
completed a senior level at USA
Wrestling events you know he said it's
not Daniel Cormier level no he's a
jitter guy yeah phenomenal jujitsu man
want to so many [ __ ] to time I would
Dhabi combat yeah Wow nightmare in his
north/south choke they called the Munson
look at it Jim that's it you got Munson
come see me this weekend Raleigh North
Carolina at good nights we are gonna
rock it rock it hard have a good night
you know I'm saying brother you have a
good night and then I want to see you
guys at helium I'll see you helium
portal
it's all my favorite clubs yep June 21
22 23 one more show we've added July
19th Thalia Hall in Chicago Brennan
shopping Thursday yeah betim will be
opening for me I will be then doing one
hour warming up for Friday right is the
big dog are you shooting one show on
Friday or two shows to chefs Friday to
Scheels Friday
we're shooting button they're recording
both yeah maybe I can get him to shoot
Thursday you don't need three don't be a
[ __ ] about it all right you know if you
can't get knock it out on to Wyatt
find out for you come see me you got
this brother
where you gonna be ice house June 15th
that's next Friday I think there's less
than 50 tickets left one show one night
only ice house than June 22nd 23rd I'm
in Houston Houston improv and then
tickets for a Cherokee Casino in
Oklahoma just went on sale
July 7th the big UFC so I'm doing an
hour stand-up before the UFC starts then
stay and watch UFC with me in person
July 7th Cherokee Casino tea fat cake on
four tickets this is the fire kid we're
out